والصلاه والسلام على من لا نبي من بعده
واعلموا عباد الله ان الله تعالى امرنا
بامر بدا فيه بنفسه وثنى
بملائكه قدسه وثلث بالمؤمنين من عالم جنه
وانسه وقال تعالى قولا كريما تعظيما لقدر
نبينا وتفهيم لنا
وتعليما ان ان الله وملائكته يصلون على
النبي يا ايها الذين امنوا صلوا عليه
وسلموا
تسليما اللهم صل على سيدنا محمد وعلى ال
سيدنا
محمد كما صليت على سيدنا ابراهيم وعلى ال
سيدنا ابراهيم انك حميد مجيد وبارك على
سيدنا محمد وعلى ال سيدنا محمد كما باركت
على سيدنا ابراهيم وعلى ال سيدنا ابراهيم
في العالمين انك حميد مجيد مكمل العلوم
الاولين والاخرين مولانا ومولى الثقلين
ابي القاسم ابي الزهراء محمد فيا ايها
الراجون شفاعته اكثروا من الصلاه والتسليم
عليه فان صلاتكم نور على الصراط حين تمرون
عليه جزاكم الله
خيرا اما
بعد ا
مسلمز
ازي are in
bless
days
حج الله سبحانه
وتعالى
‏revelation ى عليهه
وسلم
days us the
father
ابراه
us
gu
[Silence]
اسماعيل عليه
السلام ابن كثير رحمه الله
تعالى حديث
‏please l me your and
heart so that we can a few in the lives
of عليهما
السلام ابراهيم عليه السلام
الله سبحانه
وتعالى الله سبحانه
وتعالى
وبشرناه بغلام
حليم
سيدنا ابراهيم عليه
السلام
20 his wife
sar said to
him
my
me
myed me
of my
[Silence]
هاجر
سار سيدنا ابراهيم عليه
السلام
‏her do
you
her
do
life
الله
[Silence]
اسماعيل
سيدنا ابراهيم عليه
السلام صلى الله عليه
وسلم ‏who united land in the east
and صل الله عليه
وسلم
bl صلى الله عليه
وسلم after
سيدنا ابراهيم عليه السلام
هاجر اسماعيل عليه
السلام سيدنا
ابراهيم
8 اسحاق
اي
ابراهي
اسحاق
اسماعيل
‏bl
grand سيدنا ابراهيم عليه
السلام جزا الله
خير
بان دكتور
نان س
اسماعيل
سار ج سار
جج
سيدنا ابراهيم عليه
السلام سيدنا ابراهيم عليه
[Silence]
السلام
سيدنا ابراهيم عليه
point
house there very few
people there that time and
there them some
[Silence]
سيدنا ابراهيم عليه
السلام
[Silence]
سيدنا ابراهيم عليه
السلام
دعا
قران
ربنا اني اسكنت من ذريتي بواد غير ذي زرع
عند بيتك
المحرم ربنا ليقيم
الصلاه فاجعل افئده من الناس تهوي
اليهم وارزقهم من الثمرات لعلهم
[Silence]
يشكرون ‏establish
pray sof people
hearts them and bl them with bounty so
they will be
thankful soon the out and and
اسمايل began to feel
thirsty the he
ص could
[Silence]
any
‏and this s
times until
finally she he the
voice and asked it for
help help
me at that
point
ang the
over
زز صلى الله عليه
وسلم
الله
اسماعيلز
‏not and
father
the
house
more
the from
[Silence]
ج اسمايل عليه
السلام
عيد ان شاء الله
تعالى اللهم انصر الاسلام والمسلمين واعلي
كلمتي الحق والدين المبين اللهم ارنا الحق
حقا وفقنا اتباعه وارنا الباطل باطل
ووفقنا اجتنابه اللهم من اراد بالمسلمين
سوء امين فاجعل دائره السوء تدور عليه
وانصرنا عليهم يا رب العالمين اللهم فرج
هم المهمومين ونفس كرب المكروبين وارحم
الميتين و وفك اسر الماسورين واحقن دماء
المسلمين اللهم احقن دماء المسلمين في
سوريا والعراق وفلسطين وافغانستان
والشيشان اللهم وفي باكستان ومن مار
والصومال ومصر
وفي كل مكان يا رب العالمين اللهم وفقنا
لما تحب وترضى اللهم وجنبنا الفتن ما ظهر
منها وما بطن اللهم ات انفسنا تقواها
وزكها انت خير من زكاها انت وليها ومولاها
اللهم انا نعوذ بك من علم لا ينفع ومن قلب
لا يخشع ومن عين لا تدمع ومن نفس لا تشبع
ومن دعوه لا يستجاب لها واخر دعوانا ان
الحمد لله رب العالمين امين ان الله يامر
بالعدل والاحسان وايتاء ذي القربى وينهى
عن الفحشاء والمنكر والبغي يعظكم لعلكم
تذكرون واقم الصلاه يرحمك
الله الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان لا اله
الا الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول الله حي على
الصلاه